just want to take you into Chicago where the R&B singer R Kelly has been released from a Chicago prison Cook County sheriff's spokeswoman er Sofia and sorry I said that the musician has been released after someone who paid a hundred sixty one thousand dollars in child support are Kelly not saying too much there apart from the fact that EE promises to her streets and everything out and that he loves his fans this limb comes her three days after judge ordered Kelly jailed until he paid the total amount he owed by that date mr. Kelly was charged last month with ten counts of aggravated sexual abuse pertaining to four women including three who were minors when the alleged abuse occurred